my fellow Americans and by Americans I
mean only the people who voted for me
I'll never concede concession speeches
are for losers and I'm no loser folks I
beat myself in the general election
which is practically impossible I'm a
winner this is a total disgrace I
disavow this election I'm staying right
behind this desk no matter what you
can't replace me and definitely not with
a woman me too
[Music]
[Applause]
I won a popular boat this is white
genocide white genocide I'll call the
Electoral College they like me where's
the nuclear football get me the nuclear
football
what's the number eight six seven five
three oh wow and that's how the Trump
presidency came to an end and then
things got really weird president Jill
Stein taking the oath of office
no one likes losing but my family looked
on it as an opportunity to come home to
New York City how are you welcome
beautifully no you traitor Trump's first
year out of office was very difficult
Melania Trump files for divorce just
hours after her husband leaves office
and is immediately spotted canoodling
with Super Bowl MVP Colin Kaepernick the
iconic Trump Tower has been renamed
Amazon Tower after being purchased for
pennies on the dollar by Jeff Bezos that
was a low point even lower than my other
lowest point with the kids in cages our
butt
ah is how you got you take demands
buildings away you are a fly on donald
trump's windshield but the president
came back in a big way
[Music]
should be the president is vodka
could you help me with the posters these
condos aren't gonna sell themselves shut
up daddy I'm on the phone Bank of Cyprus
what do you mean you will not give us a
loan we made you and we can still break
you I don't care about the money anymore
I don't want to hear about we don't have
any more money dad dad what I did
exactly what you said and I paid out
every single one of our investors you
moron I said take out the money not pay
out what's in it
Blanca what about a foot massage she
always gets to do it she always will
there you go Oh
you